if you're headed to the fashion show
mall this week trying to snaz up your
wardrobe perhaps
well you're going to see some new
artwork there as well alex yeah there's
a featured exhibit there by a local pop
artist and bianca holman joins us there
live with a look at that hey bianca good
morning
hey good morning john good morning alex
i am inside this immersive experience
it's artwork everywhere and it's
inspired by summer and guess what the
artist behind
this amazing work he's here we're going
to talk to him pretty done
come on over look he's even doing
artwork on the mirrors and the windows
there
so good morning thanks for waking up
early he tells me he's a night owl so
this is early for him
so tell us what inspired you to do all
this great work
i'm inspired by happiness and summer
time and feel good
vibes and funny faces and weird
vibrations and we noticed that each and
every and chad look up
each and every one of these are
different so how do you just
how do you keep it all in your head or
what what promotes you to do one with
a triangle eye one with a curly cue eye
uh i try to not repeat myself and just
have fun and honestly not think
just go and let the paint
uh flow and just let it let it happen
how it does
yeah and i know that people you know
guests and and those who are shoppers
have been able to come in and meet you
what has that
vibe been like for you you know to have
people watch you as you do your work
it's been amazing to meet people and see
their reactions and uh
yeah see how they feel and lots of
people been connecting
and saying hey what is this where do i
find you
i could do this for you i could do that
that's cool with me let's
talk and you know what what do you want
people to feel when they leave when they
walk in
and when they walk out of this location
here with your exhibit and awkward what
artwork what do you want them to feel so
here at fashion show las vegas i want
them to feel
happiness fun positivity
summer time love yeah for sure and
definitely again you see the summertime
inspired like right here when you walk
in we've got the beach with the baby
shark in there the taco
got me hungry this morning a little
chicken and a cup of we don't know
what's in that cup
we'll leave it to the imagination right
it's all the imagination
all right well thank you so much pretty
done and again you can come and meet him
today and tomorrow and then it'll be up
here it'll be here for a limited time
here at fashion show mall so we're going
to send it back to you guys in the
studio
even his jacket i know even the jacket
and the mask too i love it and the hat
that's
that's awesome bianca so fashionable all
right thanks bianca we'll see you later